Rick Neuheisel joining me here on Rich
Eisen show in the Honda inside a report
how are you Rick rich I am fantastic in
happy holidays I didn't realize you
would ask for Shay Patterson for for
your holiday present you know what he
fits very nicely under the tree I'm
assuming he's he went to Michigan Ole
Miss from Ole Miss to Michigan Kazu
should we assume that car boss basically
told him he's going to start should we
assume no I don't I don't know that you
can do that but I think that he'll have
been given the assurance that he'll have
every opportunity to win the job okay
which is which is standard protocol with
coaches to quarterbacks but obviously a
Michigan feeling like they're just that
much away from getting back into the
conversation when we're talking playoffs
yeah and speaking of the playoffs do you
think the committee got it right with
the four that's going to play it out
coming up in a couple weeks rich I do I
think they got it right I know Big Ten
fans and Ohio State fans are
disappointed this is now the second year
in a row a Big Ten Champion has not made
it but the committee has to sit there
and weigh all these factors and at the
end of the day you can't unsee that 55
to 24 drubbing they took at the hands of
Iowa in Iowa City as that that loss cost
them their chance and when it all comes
down to it I guess you just have to use
the eye test at the end because I still
have no idea it's it's sort of like the
cat rule in the NFL sometimes you know
it yeah it's it's all written out but
sometimes you have to use a different
interpretation on occasion 100% it's the
Supreme Court an obscenity right i I
don't sure how to define it but I know
it when I see it and and and that's
where we are and it's it's a nun it's an
unfair situation we put these 13 people
in because I mean goodness gracious they
have to make a call they know they're
gonna upset somebody and eventually we
have to grow this play off to include
all portions of the country so that
we're not sitting there having this
argument every year Rick Neuheisel
joining me here in the Honda inside a
report which now that we've seen all the
regular season action which quarterback
that's set for the next level allegedly
for this coming year do you think is the
best quarter
back prospect for the National Football
League work well I I think that day's
end
assuming that football is important to
ISM as I hope that it is I think Josh
Rosen is going to be sensational he can
make every throw he he's certainly
cerebral enough to start to detect
what's going on in the defense's he
knows how to work the inside of the
field it's not just a sideline passer
he's not working just with the rpoS that
college football rules allow the run
Pass options so he's he's adept at all
of it and I think I think will acclimate
quickly to the NFL game but that being
said I think Darnell is special
I think he's got that John Wayne it
factor I think that the Baker Mayfield
has the ability despite maybe a little
bit short and stature I think he's like
Drew Brees I think he can throw people
open as well as anybody and those three
guys I think would be the ones that
would come to mind quickest to make a
difference at the next level so let's go
in order here Rosen why do we keep
talking about his want to his desire why
is that constantly being the
conversation Rick because he talks about
it I mean and not necessarily to a
microphone when he's on but he talks
about it behind the scenes you know he's
he's an affluent comes from an affluent
family where it wasn't always important
to be a professional athlete now I think
as he's gotten closer to the to the
flame kind of thing I think he's feeling
the allure and the challenge of it and
so I think that we'll all be kind of
gone by the wayside after he gets poked
and prodded in Indianapolis at the
combine yeah I mean that is gonna be the
topic that I mean the interview process
that is going to be the crucial aspect
of his combine not the height weight
measurement and how what his hand size
is or not gonna do in these drills but
it's what he's gonna do in the meeting
rooms you've been in those rooms how do
you how do you test somebody's want to
how do you do well it will be
interesting you know I was with the
raven franchise so Ozzie Newsome would
he cut to the chase I mean he goes I
know you practice these answers because
an agent helped you
you know script exactly what you'd say
to all this stuff let's just cut through
this this minutia and get to the real
and I think everybody in some way shape
or form is going to
try to do the same thing and so it's
important that it isn't a scripted
answer it's important to come from his
heart and they they believe it his
sincerity but if if you get past that
and remember it only takes one I think
he's going to be really really special
because he does have all those
attributes you look for in a signal
color Rick Neuheisel and the Honda
inside a report would you counseled
Arnold to stay in school you know I
would I think he's enjoying the game you
know I don't know what the economics are
do you have to have somebody that
understands all that in terms of what
present value is and and so forth but I
think you know he still has a
inclination to throw into coverage I
think he still can take another year and
learn what's going on on the other side
of the ball take another step in terms
of changing plays at the line of
scrimmage and getting the Trojans into
better situations and I think you know
he could benefit from that and I think
obviously USC fans would be ecstatic if
he were to make that choice and then the
the last one that you mentioned Baker
Mayfield the fact that he can get
triggered by Kansas does that concern
you when you go to the next level
they're gonna be a lot of people poking
and prodding him on that you look like a
biology frog you know it it'll be it'll
be asked but I think the chip on his
shoulder as much as it might be a
concern to some might be an alluring
tour factor force but for others the
fact that he loves to compete at that
much remember this guy was a walk on
walk on both the Texas Tech and Oklahoma
he's been to New York City as a Heisman
finalist three years in a row he's
thrown 41 touchdown passes after its own
40 the year before the guy flat can
throw people open he extends plays as
well as any and he has this as he likes
determine a boulder on his shoulder I
think people like that competitive deal
well I've said a couple of times now
Rick and I might as well bounce it off
you that you know Washington Redskins
fans think that there's no way out
because cousins might be there might not
be there and that they're there and that
the front office is caught in a rock and
a hard place
I think drafted Baker Mayfield and
thrown him in the NFC East and try and
do battle with dak and whence and
whatever the future is for the giant
that's the spot for this kid I know that
makes a lot of sense as you say it now
that makes a lot of sense and and you
know Jay Gruden would be smart to borrow
a little bit of that Oklahoma offense to
come with him you know that's what Bill
O'Brien was doing with deshaun Watson we
saw that the effects once he got
comfortable with the offense they did
that with Jared Goff and year two with
is with the Rams
if they bring a little that Oklahoma
Lincoln Riley offense with them
I think Mayfield will be really really
good in DC a couple of more minutes with
Rick Neuheisel and the Honda inside a
report how do you think Chip Kelly's
gonna fare in your old stomping grounds
at UCLA I'd like to hire I think and I'm
speaking as a former Bruin player not a
former Bruin coach I think it signals
that that UCLA is ready to make the all
end statement you don't take that job if
you're Chip Kelly given the leverage
that he had unless you have assurances
that all things that you need to be at
the at your best as a program nationally
are in place meaning nutrition meaning
strength and conditioning budgets all
those things are there you don't spend
twenty three and a half million bucks on
a coach to come do it if you're not
going to give them the tools that are
necessary to compete at the highest
level and I know chip knew the questions
to ask and so I feel good about the hire
and I think all former Bruins like
myself are excited about the prospect
all right let's talk about you hosting
the American Football Coaches Awards yes
Rich Eisen type role well I appreciate
that you'd throw my name in that mix
Rick but I was going more Billy Crystal
you're gonna have like a song and dance
routine you're gonna have a guitar
Barney Bonnie Bernstein who's going to
be my co-host okay demanding that she'd
get a vocal opportunity so we will have
the guitar and so Rick you yeah this is
on january 9th it's the day after the
national championship that we're going
to be in Charlotte North Carolina which
is the site of the American Football
Coaches convention so all the coaches
both current and former will be there
it's it's a chance to to hang out where
you can see this on USA Today sports
Facebook page
that's eight o'clock Eastern Time we're
gonna get out the coach of the Year
award last year Mike McIntyre from
Colorado won it
Scott frost will be probably a guy at
the top of the list this year
we're gonna present the number one team
who've won the night before and his
coach the Amway coaches poll this is all
sponsored by Amway which is cool but
here's what's neat you can go on to
cameo with the coaches dot-com and sign
up for a chance to win a trip for two to
Charlotte and come be part of the show
you're gonna be on TV rub elbows with
all these guys drop a couple ball place
slip it into your favorite coaches best
pocket and you can be a part of this
thing hang out with me we'll write songs
I mean what more do you want it's a
kumbaya moment I promise you yeah you
know we actually speaking of which we
actually set Nick Saban's soliloquy
about torn-up jeans
we sent we set it to country music Rick
because it sounded like did you hear a
soliloquy about this I did hear about
this it sounded what what did we come to
how did we get here was what that was
what that was like don't that I will I
will write the song and have it
available for you as soon as you are
ready to demand see fit to have it
available no we already we already have
you already did it yeah would you like
would you like to hear it right with me
that would be wondering yeah here here
we go Mike tell two phones gonna get it
don't worry I we could edit this thing
like go ahead hang on one second Rick
we're gonna we're gonna put this thing
together can you get it Mike yeah okay
hold on here we go
you got it Mike
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just wanted to know how we got here
not to offend anybody out there but I
just walked by some jeans wore out jeans
holes in them all cut up I just remember
when I was a kid in West Virginia I just
seem to go to school cut my jeans were
wore out only because we didn't have any
better now they bond that way I just
wanted to know how we got here
I just want to know how we got here I
think it's a hit Rick what do you think
there's no question who knew that Nick
Saban would be as good as the possum in
terms of articulating the country yeah
well that that's and that's an option
for you for hosting uh for your for your
opening act although I think if you if
you would take one last request before I
let you go here you should your entrance
should be Texas A&M jet comes on stage
you come out roll out the red carpet and
a band treats you like you're a visiting
dignitary just like what happened with
Jimbo what do you think I think that's
appropriate I mean I don't think I
haven't seen the small print in this
deal that I'm signing I don't think it's
for ten years nor for 75 million but I
think whatever the budget is Rick what's
Busta that's all I'm saying
hey I look forward to it let's chat soon
okay I look forward to it happy Holidays
to you enjoy the bowl season and it goes
fast doesn't it this no nor does cameo
at the coaches.com at coach neuheisel on
twitter rick neuheisel here in the Honda
inside report the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience